bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
sociologique pour une petite vidéo tuto
aujourd'hui on va apprendre comment
faire de la sociologie alors la
sociologie c'est la science qui étudie
la société donc on n'a pas le choix il
va falloir qu'on aille dans la société
pour pouvoir l'étudier davantage c'est
que la société il y en a partout dont va
pas avoir besoin d'aller bien loin allez
je vous emmène pour une petite virée
recherche et voilà et maintenant qu'on
est dans la société et nous reste plus
qu'a
[Musique]
fait de la sociologie
pour répondre à cette question le mieux
c'est encore de demander à des
professionnels on est justement ici à
l'université de nantes où on va pouvoir
rencontrer des sociologues deux métiers
et essayer de comprendre un peu comment
il crée de la connaissance on est ici au
sens le centre nantais de sociologie
c'est le laboratoire de sociologie
affilié à l'université de nantes qui
nous a ouvert ses portes pendant une
semaine pour qu'on puisse rencontrer les
sociologues et parler de leur travail
allez venez
bon prenons quand même quelques secondes
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet car
c'est quand même mon tout premier
partenariat de la chan ça se fête cette
vidéo est réalisée dans le cadre du
projet vidéo la bo de nantes universités
c'est un projet soutenu par la région
pays de la loire et le fonds européen de
développement régional qui finance pour
la deuxième année consécutive des
vidéastes pour faire connaître le
travail des scientifiques de
l'université
l'année dernière trois vidéos avaient
été réalisés sur les missions spatiales
les échanges internationaux et la
consommation d'insectes et cette année
j'ai été sélectionné avec trois autres
vidéaste pour aborder de nouveaux sujets
tous les liens seront bien sûr dans la
description
personnellement je suis donc en
partenariat avec le centre nantais de
sociologie et le cnrs pour vous
permettre de mieux comprendre le travail
des sociologues et justement ne perdons
pas plus de temps c'est la question du
jour comment travaille un sociologue on
l'a souvent l'impression que la science
est une activité solitaire c'est l'image
du génie qui arrive tout seul à créer
une invention incroyable depuis quand
êtes vous un expert en astrophysique
thermonucléaire et asseoir mais comme la
plupart des créations de l'humanité la
science c'est avant tout une activité
collective enfin on n'écrit jamais tout
seul
dans la recherche je pense dans aucune
discipline en fait c'est à dire quoi
en permanence on va lire ou aller dans
des colloques un peu moins depuis deux
ans on va dire pour confronter ce qu'on
fait et nos terrains aux recherches des
autres on dit aussi qu'on s'appuie sur
la littérature je n'ai pas la
littérature recense nobel de littérature
est plutôt au sens les écrits
scientifiques etc donc on le fait en
permanence une des manières dont tu peux
reconnaître un texte scientifique c'est
qu'il est référencée et il dit toujours
comment ils se situent par rapport à ce
qu'on appelle parfois l'état de l'art
c'est-à-dire les autres travaux
antérieurs sur tel ou tel sujet tel et
tel concept etc si t'as pas à ça
tu qu'on peut dire c'est une condition
nécessaire pour faire un texte
scientifique donc ce travail au delà on
fait systématiquement même en sociologie
bon on pourrait penser que le sociologue
il est a priori tout seul face à son
terrain en fait il n'est pas rare du
tout que les projets se fassent en
groupe en collaboration oui parce que si
votre image d'un scientifique qui fait
du terrain ça ressemble à une espèce
dina jones qui part à l'aventuré tout
seul et qui arrive à la fois sauver le
monde et à faire avancer la science il
va falloir revoir un peu les bases la
recherche elle se déroule tout d'abord
dans les universités au sein des
laboratoires affiliés aux facultés et au
cas où vous vous demandez à quoi ça
ressemble en laboratoire en sociologie
comme le sens c'est principalement un
long couloir avec des bureaux en
enfilade dans lesquelles travaillent les
maîtres de conférences et les doctorants
quand ils ne sont pas en train de faire
des cours ou sur le terrain du coup au
sein d'un labo il ya de la discussion et
des projets de recherche peuvent se
monter entre plusieurs chercheurs qui
s'intéressent à une même question au
cours de mon séjour j'ai justement eu la
chance de pouvoir suivre en projets de
recherche en train de se monter par deux
chercheurs de l'inrs spé alors line spé
c'est l'institut national supérieur du
professorat et de l'éducation c'est à
dire c'est le lieu où sont formés les
futurs professeurs de l'éducation
nationale les deux sociologues que je
suis gildas loire ans et jean balan
entame tout juste une recherche sur des
étudiants qui se destinent à devenir
professeur des écoles
plus précisément il s'intéresse à un
nouveau statut celui des alternants qui
sont des étudiants qui se retrouvent à
être en responsabilité devant des
classes de primaire en plus de faire
leur formation en master du coup ils se
retrouvent avec la double contrainte de
devoir passer un diplôme exigeant tout
en découvrant le métier d'enseignant
avec un encadrement parfois réduits ce
qui a laissé entrevoir un certain nombre
de problèmes bon j'ai pu proposer vois
que j'ai tapé disponible du point de vue
des objets de recherche j'ai pu enfin
bon ce serait bien
on ouvre une enquête sur ces alternances
eu un statut tout à fait nouveau pour la
première fois pendant cet objet de
recherche on avait décidé aujourd'hui de
réunir les alternants un peu édifiant
j'arrive donc ici juste après la phase
exploratoire de la travail qui a
consisté à faire un entretien croisé
avec quatre étudiants en alternance pour
pouvoir aborder avec eux les points qui
leur pose problème et le travail de
recherche il commence donc maintenant 1
lors de la phase de débriefing où les
chercheurs confronter leurs analyses
pour faire émerger des axes de recherche
principaux mais comme son nom l'indiqué
cette phase exploratoire n'est que la
première étape d'une enquête qui va
maintenant demander à être affinée et
formaliser donc là vous avez fait cette
étude de préparatoires avec les
entretiens
et du coût de l'énergie l'étape d'après
c'est quoi on va surtout là on a à peu
identifiée ce qui nous intéressait
c'est notre première fois couverte
donc chacun a ses petites préoccupations
c'est vrai qu'on a relevé des choses qui
sont tout à fait comme une belle idée ça
va être là maintenant de d'essayer
d'élaborer une ébauche de questionnaires
le boulot est assez lourd parce que ça
va consister à transformer on va dire
c'est double chose et on va dire des
questions que la recherche peut se poser
les questions que se posent les
alternants eux mêmes par rapport à leur
avenir etc et puis donner une forme à
nos questions et nous manière
d'interroger qui de bâti soit en phase
avec ce que sont les gens et ce qu'ils
font en mesure de répondre qu'ils ne
soient pas
sur le sur le mode de l'imposition de
problématiques quoi pour leur part le 2
et puis la dernière dernier élément
c'est qu'il va falloir qu'on le
transforme en quelque chose d'accessible
c'est à dire que quand tu répond à un
questionnaire il faut que tu comprennes
les questions que les questions soient
soient unies vote et ça ce dernier
travaille c'est un travail de forme mais
la forme est jamais dissocié du fonds
est donc et ce travail prend aussi du
temps parce que un bon questionnaire
c'est aussi un questionnaire qui est
compréhensible et qui ne prenne pas trop
de temps alors c'est sûr en termes de
réponse tu peux pas parce que si tu fais
un très beau questionnaire et que tu
mets deux heures répondre
c'est possible mais ça exige le face à
face
il faut qu'on puisse avoir quelque chose
d'assez efficace en terme de durée bon
je reviendrai plus tard sur les
subtilités de la confection d'un
questionnaire mais ça permet de voir
comment se lancent une étude et comment
des chercheurs collaborent pour fonder
un objet de recherche les
enseignants-chercheurs partagent leur
temps entre l'enseignement et la
recherche
et ils sont libres d'ouvrir des terrain
d'investigation comme c'est le cas ici
cela dit si cette enquête a pu s'ouvrir
aussi facilement ici c'est
principalement parce que les chercheurs
étudient directement linth paix dans
lequel ils travaillent dans les faits
les sociologues peuvent rarement choisir
aussi librement leurs sujets de
recherche c'est à dire que oui tu vas
être payés pour faire la recherche et la
recherche que tu veux ça d'accord mais
tu ne peut le faire que à deux
conditions c'est premièrement si ta
recherche ne coûte absolument rien
c'est à dire tu as besoin d'aucun
instrument t'as pas besoin de te
déplacer sur le terrain n'a pas besoin
de faire travailler des gens avec toi
donc si vraiment ça coûte absolument
rien tu peux faire ce que tu veux la
deuxième condition c'est tu n'as
absolument aucune ambition de carrière
c'est à dire que tu acceptes de n'avoir
aucune carrière au sens promotion
primes gratifications symbolique et que
c est à ces deux conditions
tu peux faire absolument la recherche
que tu dans les faits les chercheurs
doivent donc se joindre à des projets
plus ambitieux par exemple répondant à
des demandes de la part d'organismes
publics ou privés ou au montant des
projets de recherche pour obtenir des
financements en plus les recherches
elles sont financées sur projet c'est à
dire que si tu veut de l'argent pour la
recherche il faut déposer un projet donc
ça veut dire qu'une grosse part du
travail s'est inventé un projet écrire
un projet soumettre un projet pour avoir
de l'argent et dans l'immense majorité
les projets ils sont pas financés enfin
je veux dire les projets vont pas être
acceptées donc ça veut dire que pour
avoir un projet accepté et financé il
faut en écrire plein on se retrouve donc
dans une situation que je trouve
personnellement un peu absurde où on
passe presque plus de temps à monter des
projets qu'à faire réellement de la
recherche et où on utilise de plus en
plus le temps pourtant précieux des
enseignants chercheurs pour faire des
tâches administratives
mais bon on arrive quand même parfois à
s'en sortir pour faire des recherches un
peu longue ambitieuse et il ya même un
moment un peu particulier dans la vie
d'un chercheur c'est le moment de la
thèse de fait une fois le financement de
thèse obtenus en ce n'est pas gagné non
plus le doctorant va se plonger à fond
dans son sujet auquel il consacre la
majeure partie de son temps mais même
pour ceux qui travaillent a priori tout
seul comme c'est le cas des doctorants
qui font leur thèse de doctorat pendant
trois ans et même bien souvent en
sociologie quatre ou cinq et bien en
fait ils sont loin de travailler
uniquement tout seul sur le projet de
thèse parce qu'il ya plein de moments
ils vont interagir avec la communauté
scientifique par exemple lorsqu'ils
présentent leur travail lors de
colloques ou va y avoir des échanges ou
aussi lorsqu'ils écrivent des articles
pour des revues à comité de lecture qui
vont leur faire des retours critiques
sur leur travail qui vont prendre en
compte est intégré à leur raisonnement
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas quelque
chose qu'on a forcément en tête si on
est pas familier du travail de recherche
mais un doctorant ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui s'enferme dans son bureau pendant
quatre ans puis qui en ressort un beau
jour avec les cheveux en bataille l'oeil
torve et la publie clignotantes avec un
manuscrit de 1500 pages à la main on
attend au contraire d'un chercheur qu'il
communique sur son travail en parallèle
de sa thèse d'abord en écrivant des
articles dans des revues si possible
prestigieuse mais aussi en participant à
des communications comme des colloques
des séminaires ou des journées d'études
alors un colloque 1 c'est lorsqu'une
revue en laboratoire ou une université
par exemple lance un appel à
communication autour d'un thème et que
plusieurs chercheurs répondent à cet
appel pour présenter certains le
résultat est d'en discuter avec la
communauté scientifique
et si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le
sujet je vous recommande la très bonne
vidéo que vient de sortir charlotte sur
sa chaîne les langues de chat où elle
discute des enjeux et des
fonctionnements des colloques
scientifiques notre côté on va insister
sur certains aspects de la communication
scientifique avec le dr joseph godefroy
alors joseph c'est un doctorant qui en
dernière année de thèse à l'université
de nantes et il travaille sur la
professionnalisation des utilisateurs
d'instagram il s'intéresse plus
particulièrement à les influenceurs
fitness et cuisine et ils essayent
d'observer comment se fait la transition
d'une activité de loisir à une activité
marchandises et en partenariat avec les
marques il a déjà fait de nombreuses
communications scientifiques sur son
travail je lui ai donc demandé de nous
expliquer plus largement l'importance de
ces journées d'études et aussi de
l'écriture d'articles pour la conduite
d'une recherche en sciences sociales
donc dans mon casque et est ce qu'on
m'avait conseillé de faire et ce que
j'ai essayé de faire c'était à chaque
fois de d'aller sur des colloques et des
communications qui allait me servir
qu'elle aime porte me forcer à écrire et
qui allait avoir un effet directement
sur la production de la thèse ça a été
un moyen de discuter des points
très précis et ça ma foi réorienter
amusant ben ali ont ça en fait même avec
du recul mais j'aurais jamais dû parler
de ça maintenant c'est évident que près
les discussions que j'ai eues avec telle
ou telle personne qui m'ont invité à
lire telle ou telle chose et bien
maintenant c'est évident qu'il faut que
je fasse comme ça ou qu'il faut inscrire
le travail de telle façon et après au
niveau des articles ça c'est venu un peu
plus tard le premier travail d'écriture
que j'ai fait c'était il ya deux ans
pour un article n'est pas encore sorti
donc c'est un premier article qui
reprend qui se focalise sur la
mobilisation économie des influenceurs
donc c'est le concept que j'essaie de
2,2 forme et que donc c'est un papier
qui doit sortir bientôt
c'est toujours un peu le mystère de ces
revues on en discutant avec maître
directeur de thèse on a toujours
pris au sérieux en fait ce travail
d'écriture dans d'articles même s'ils
étaient longs parallèle à la culture de
la thèse et des fois je n'ai finalement
ralentir le rythme et d'écriture de la
thèse mais parce que c'était un moment
de discussion qui était très fin avec
avec des collègues et qui ont amené à
faire évoluer encore l'analyse qui était
la mienne sur sur ce travail là à chaque
fois j'ai reçu des retours très très
précis très denses et donc à la fois
difficile à digérer parce que c'est
parce que tu te dis là j'ai passé on
compte même pas parce que sinon c'est
vraiment déprimant j'ai passé énormément
de temps là visiblement il ya plein de
choses qui vont pas donc il faut se dire
d'accord donc c'est des gens d'un point
de vue extérieur qui le disent ils ont
un recul que je n'ai pas et donc il faut
arriver à faire a pesé le pour et le
contre pour produire une meilleure
proposition alors la publication
d'articles ce n'est pas du tout anodin
dans la carrière d'un doctorant parce
que c'est principalement là dessus qu'il
va être évaluée en tant que chercheur ça
a de fait plusieurs effets pervers sur
le monde scientifique mais pour ça je
vous renvoie à la vidéo de dirt et
biologie sur la mafia scientifiques dont
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler qui
traitent très bien du sujet dit tout
simplement que la carrière d'un
chercheur dépend assez directement du
nombre d'articles qu'il fait publier et
du type de revue dans laquelle une
public parce que c'est pas pareil
d'avoir un article dans la revue
française de sociologie ou dans les
actes de la recherche en sciences
sociales qui sont les deux revues
françaises plus prestigieuses ou dans la
revue société dirigée par michel
maffesoli est tristement célèbre pour
avoir laissé passer en 2015 un article
lu r sur la mobilité postmoderne de
l'autolib auto toujours
mobilisation qatar type de conduite du
mouvement des corps mais surtout
après il ya évidemment des revues qui
ont pas la même légitimité scientifique
donc on fait aussi l'objet d'évaluations
donc les revues sont elles mêmes
classes et sur des grands king
internationaux est ce que ses rangs
aaron beran c est là bas quand on veut
publier dans une revue qui a un crédit
académique et ben c'est une revue dans
lesquelles il ya des comités de lecture
ça veut dire dans lesquels il ya une
évaluation systématiser par au moins
deux parfois trois personnes de
l'article qu'on a soumis en vue d'être
publiés dans la revue et là ça veut dire
que c'est des pères qui sont eux aussi
spécialisé de la discipline et de nos
objets ou des approches mobilisés dans
l'article qu'on a soumis qui vont faire
une double évaluation à l'aveuglé en
caserne c'est pas qui est qui sont
censés être des experts et à propos de
l'écriture d'articles scientifiques on a
pu en discuter un peu plus en détail
avec ludivine ballan qui venait
justement de recevoir les retours d'une
revue après qu'elle a soumis un article
avec deux coups l'autrice
quand tu envoies un article et un il ya
le comité de rédaction qui se réunit des
experts qui vont lire et qui vont
produire des évaluations sur ton article
donc là on a reçu une évaluation avec 4
évaluateurs et ils nous proposent de
rectifier
à de préciser de restructurer le papier
et c'est alors tout les évaluateurs ne
propose pas les mêmes choses si tu
arrives à rectifier à
modifier à ta version eh bien tu peux
repropose et ont marqué que dans cette
même revue et puis tu vas avoir un
deuxième retour il faut savoir que dans
les grosses revue là c'est une revue
assez importante en sociologie
le délai de publication est d'environ
deux ans
entre le moment où tu soumettent et le
moment où l'article est publié ou pas
publiés
parce que des fois on se voit là ça
c'est l'article si tu veux voilà c'est
juste des petits commentaires de la
revue la revue a fait aussi des
commentaires donc on rajoute des choses
etc mais comme nous sommes à trois eh
bien il va falloir que nous travaillons
toutes les trois à certains moments sur
sur cet article donc il faut aussi qu'on
ait des codes couleurs pour se retrouver
pour pour mais je pense que ça ne va pas
toujours facile du coup de recevoir la
presse et le jeu aussi de la science
fait un come back en position
à des moments et des moments
particuliers ta ta ta le moment de
grande satisfaction au moment où tu
envoies l'article at il dit a
l'impression d'avoir fait quelque chose
tu fais tu es tu dis ça y est j'ai j'ai
produit j'ai fait quelque chose et puis
après arrive un temps assez long en
général au minimum deux mois avant
d'avoir le premier retour et là le
retour
en général fait toujours mal parce que
nous sommes évalués par nos pairs ce
sont des enseignants chercheurs qui
comme nous vont être dans les comités de
rédaction
gratuitement il faut le préciser est
et qui vont faire ce travail de lecture
de relecture de correction de alors mais
les experts sont variés et ils ont aussi
des manières de faire qui sont variées y
en a qui sont plus ou moins bienveillant
il y en a qui m'ont proposé des
modifications il y en a d'autres qui
plus clairement ont un rapport plus tôt
qu'à
110 voilà analyse absolument pas
original
pour répondre à ta question il ya
toujours des moments un peu des phases
assez assez variable ou à la fois tu
peux être extrêmement content et puis tu
mets toujours quelques jours à digérer
un commentaire
et puis après tu te tue tir mais parce
que c'est ainsi que fonctionne la
science
c'est c'est l'évaluation par les pairs
c'est le fait que rien n'est jamais
parfait même quand tu as l'impression
était hyper fier de ton de ton papier de
ton article de son analyse et ben non il
faut le reprendre il faut l'améliorer et
en général c'est pour le meilleur alors
bien sûr les articles sont à la base de
la recherche mais il ne faut pas non
plus oublier la publication de livres
qui est assez foisonnante en sciences
sociales je vous montre par exemple un
petit florilège des livres écrits par
les chercheurs du sens et c'est vraiment
pas anodin parce que ce n'est pas autant
valoriser dans d'autres disciplines
comme la physique ou la biologie on en
discute avec la maîtresse de conférences
valérie roll qui a publié en 2013 son
livre l'art de tatouer la pratique d'un
métier créatif qui est issu de son
travail de thèse pour lequel elle a
étudié pendant près de sept ans la
profession assez peu régulé des
tatoueurs en france c'est vrai qu'il ya
encore une tradition du livre et une
valorisation du livre comme production
intellectuelle qui a de l'importance
aussi sur un dossier quand on postule
sur un poste et c'est pas forcément le
cas par tous avec la logique du travail
par projets et des modes de financement
de la recherche d'eau jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que ben on capitalise mieux
si on fait une succession d'articles
plutôt qu'un livre surtout si le livre
est peu reconnu et après c'est quand
même une entreprise importante parce que
dans un livre on peut dire des choses
qu'on peut pas forcément raconté dans un
article c'est à dire que l'arctique
c'est quand même un format beaucoup plus
court alors c'est très exigeant il faut
pas croire c'est très très exigeante
c'est vrai que ça demande vraiment de
traiter une dimension particulière alors
que le livre il va permettre de
davantage
s'abandonner à un travail de description
et je pense que c'est aussi ça la
richesse qui fit mangez moi j'ai eu la
chance qu'on me dise n'a pas de format
en plus on a publié plein de photos dans
le livre parce que c'était aussi ce qui
faisait l'intérêt que j'avais beaucoup
travaillé sur les images et ça c'est
génial parce qu'on peut vraiment rentré
dans le détail et faire rentrer moi j'ai
je pense dans l'écriture j'ai pu faire
rentrer les gens dans des studios mais
après d'un point de vue leurs
connaissances scientifiques
la différence c'est quand même que les
livres ils sont a priori sont pas il n'y
a pas de
comité de lecture
c'est la même chose pour les livres
c'est à dire que dans le domaine de
l'édition il ya aussi bien sûr des
maisons d'édition et des collections qui
sont plus réputés que d'autres dans
lesquelles il ya aussi des systèmes d'
expertise par les pairs et d'autres
maisons d'édition sais pas c'est pas
nécessairement le cas après ça peut
changer du même d'une collection à
l'autre d'abord donc du coup publié aux
puf par exemple ça veut dire
à
la maison des sciences de l'homme à la
découverte etc par contre à l'harmattan
c'est pas le cas ce qui veut pas dire
pour autant qu'il n'y a pas des très
bons travaux qui sont publiés mais bien
sûr les expertises par les pairs c'est
quand même une garantie bon résumons un
petit peu les sociologues qu'il soit
doctorants ou maître de conf sévissent à
l'université où il donne des cours tout
en conduisant leurs recherches ils
s'appuient sur la communauté
scientifique avant de commencer leur
terrain en lisant les études déjà
publiées sur le sujet et ils contribuent
eux aussi à agrandir le champ des
connaissances en communiquant lors de
colloques en publiant des articles des
livres qui sont évalués par leurs pairs
mais tout ça ne nous dit pas comment on
fait de la sociologie quand on revient
du terrain comment on fait la différence
entre faire vraiment de la sociologie
est juste raconter sa vie parce que si
on se réfère à ce qu'on peut trouver au
rayon sociologie de n'importe quel os
mac on comprend que des étudiants plus
avoir une image un peu fausse de la
sociologie je tirais pas une image un
peu faussée
je dirais plutôt une absence d'image qui
est peut-être s'il y avait une pas une
confusion mais au fait que ba la
sociologie et ça parle du monde social
que les étudiants bas comme tout un
chacun ils sont plongés dans le monde
social et ils ont des idées sur ce monde
social qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
prêts notions qui sont aussi des
représentations qui peut être aussi
parfois étayée par leur lecture par les
cours qu'ils ont pu suivre etc mais en
tout cas je veux dire penser qu' il
suffit de parler de son expérience pour
faire de la sociologie et ça c'est une
confusion ou à une pierre d'achoppement
que certains étudiants peuvent
rencontrer en buts cursus au moment où à
la fois je veux dire et ils ont pas
encore été initiés aux méthodes de
recherche et c'est nous c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait très tôt et puis au
moment aussi avant même bas qu'ils aient
aussi été familiarisés avec un certain
nombre de travaux d'apports théoriques
d'outils et cetera je veux dire voilà je
veux dire des outils qui permettent de
démonter bon du coup on va pas y couper
qui va falloir qu'on discute un peu de
méthode et collecte de données mais on
va se garder ça pour la vidéo suivante
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner de laisser
un commentaire si la vidéo vous a plu et
on se retrouve très vite pour la
deuxième partie
[Musique]